good morning
my name is Sarah kahalanigu I'm the
editor-in-chief of axios a U.S news
publication and thrilled today to be
monitoring today's discussion really
important discussion a global discussion
here at the world economic Forum about
the future of industrial policies we'll
have perspectives here from around the
globe from Private Industry from
government from Academia here to present
a number of perspectives about some very
pressing issues I want to welcome all of
you who have joined us here this morning
and for those of you who are watching us
streaming online and want to join the
conversation I welcome you to use the
hashtag West 23.
we'll go ahead and begin I want to set
the stage and talk about why we're here
to discuss the global disruptions that
are really forcing change upon Global
industry as you all know in the news
you've seen the headlines of the last
few years about
covid of course the pandemic really
disrupting Supply chains forcing
technology into hyperspeed and all of
the uh of course the war in Ukraine
further disruptions with Rising prices
this is all forcing a discussion about
what needs to change and what needs to
happen in global cooperation for a
global industry going forward
I want to start by introducing my guest
here with me to join this conversation
and add their perspectives I'll
introduce each of them
starting here on my right Mr Dimitri
DeVries he's co-ceo of DSM at
Netherlands based conglomerate in many
lines of business
next to me is Ms her ex Lindsay Ms Lee
Young she's minister of smes and
startups in South Korea
on my left is is um the right honorable
Grant shops he is Secretary of State for
business energy and Industrial strategy
of the UK welcome thank you and uh Mr uh
Jared um Jared Mohler as director
General of the United Nations Industrial
Development organization of Vienna he'll
be joining us shortly and finally last
but not least Mr Ricardo Houseman he's
founder and director of the growth Lab
at Harvard University in Cambridge
Massachusetts welcome so welcome to all
of you
wonderful all right we'll go ahead and
get started I'd like to start with you
Mr Mr Gervais
um you run a major corporation that's
involved in many lines of businesses
from what I understand your your company
is Reliant upon and involved in many
parts of the supply chain for many Goods
that move around the world I want to
start with you what are today still the
most the biggest challenges that you see
effective manufacturing and Industry in
particular in the global context
well it's a that's a huge question
um and as we speak we're still
struggling with it
um let's go back uh in terms of of
concept so Supply chains and
Manufacturing were engineered to be
extremely efficient
nobody wanted to take any money or stock
or Capital tied up so it was a very
smooth engine and that was completely
disrupted by covid by political tensions
geopolitical tensions and basically in
the value chain everybody took a sort of
a buffer uh and as we speak today the
question is how does that look for the
future because the end of the day
there's a cost to it
and the question is who is paying for it
so consumers don't want to pay extra
certainly not in the cost inflationary
environment uh governments don't feel it
as being their responsibility for
efficient Supply chains and correctly so
the industry in itself is coping with it
because there is a price to be paid so
all the choice about geopolitical
production who pays the price what is
the exactly the smooth entrance in terms
of supply chain is still running as we
speak and there's a lot of turmoil I've
been in many panels about that question
and there's no golden solution yet and
for your business in particular what do
you say what do you think is the most
particular issue you're still dealing
with now that hasn't fully shaken out
yeah so we have made the choice
ourselves what type of products are
essential for the world so we are in the
Health Nutrition business so we Supply
Medical Nutrition we Supply multivitamin
ingredients
and there are some products in the world
where you just cannot live without and
there the supply chain needs to be
completely different
than products which are nice to have and
I think we are making that choice but
it's a joint responsibility and that's
also why I'm in the panel for industrial
policy it's not only our responsibility
to make that choice but it's the world
to make that choice
and I want to turn to get the government
perspective from your secretary shops
about what the UK which has been clear
to government about where the gaps are
between business where business where
government can fill out to ensure a
certain stability yeah I mean we've
experienced as the whole world has these
kind of uh supply chain shortages and
they crop up in all sorts of unexpected
ways so just over a year ago we had cues
at our petrol stations something
unimaginable Unthinkable there's always
petrol at the pump if you need to go and
get it and actually the problem wasn't
anything to do with petrochemicals the
problem was to do with the Lorry drivers
the hgv drivers the truck drivers the
tanker drivers to get the petrol to the
right place from the refinery which have
plenty of petrol to the station and um
so in terms of a government response I
mean it clearly the supply chain is a
commercial issue to resolve and we've
seen these enormous movements on a
broader front for example that the
classic measure can be the cost of a
container from China uh to Europe or
China to the US to North America and we
saw that go Sky High and then fall to a
tenth of its height now government isn't
going to be able to fix that but what
government can do is the regulatory
changes uh that might be necessary to
help sort of um Grease the the wheels of
Commerce so going back to the tanker
driver shortage and the cues at Petrol
gas stations and what I did was
introduce 22 different specific measures
to essentially loosen some of the
bureaucracy around you know what does it
take to become a tanker driver you know
why is it that when you take your
driving test uh you you have to first
learn to drive a rigid truck and then a
a a a a elongated one and you have to
allow a certain number of weeks in
between between and I discovered this
came from some EU law and we're not in
the EU anymore so I didn't have to worry
about that and I was able to without
lessening the standard of the test just
take away the bureaucracy and that was
just one measure there were 21 other
measures using regulatory freedoms and
being more flexible enables us to
resolve the problem faster I think than
was than than some other locations in
the world were able to do so I think the
government has to kind of be really
creative and in particular work on the
regulatory side of things but don't you
also re-examining your Global alliances
right the US's we were having energy
crisis here in Europe it's maybe not as
bad as people feared but rethinking the
world and how Goods move around it
um so it's going to be top of mind so
one of the interesting things in a
British context is
um at the same time we'd recently come
out of the EU at this at this particular
moment in time so people will sort of
apt to say well hasn't this just
happened because you don't have free
movement of people but actually it
transpired that they had even bigger
shortages of tanker drivers in this
particular instance say in Poland and
France and Germany everyone was
suffering so the the global coordination
wasn't so much the issue but the issue
that the world has experienced
particularly through covert and then
through the Putin's war in Ukraine is
you've got to be just a little bit more
self-reliant so how do you train people
into this Market how do you make sure
that your supply chain can provide the
uh the PPE equipment you know if you
have a pandemic how do you make sure
that energy isn't reliant on unreliable
Partners so I think it has led to a
greater sense that you've got to be
self-reliant but we are great Global
Traders and we want the world to be as
open as as possible as well so I think
you'll write about those shifting Global
alliances but it's very very important
we don't slip into protectionism and
that is where at the edges the inflation
reduction act in the US is dangerous
because it could slip into protection
that's not its intention I don't think
it's necessary where where it is going
but it but if it's not amended you think
it is the intention it's like protection
yeah it is protection yes whether it's
intentional protection or not is the is
the debate attention but but I think
that you know that is where we have to
be really careful well it's a good
debate that's happening here welcome uh
Mr Moore yeah would you like to win as
we're talking about the role for what
government how government is rethinking
and policies that should be in place
given the huge disruption we already
heard from Mr DeVries about how his
company is uh rethinking where
government should fit in or not fit in
and um we welcome you to the stage thank
you it's a pleasure to be with you this
morning so which government and the
director general for unidom that's the
UN Organization for Industrial
Development
and and we deal as a a bridge between
industrialized countries and developing
countries
170 members and here in Davos we talk a
lot about consequences of these dribble
crisis pandemic Ukraine and climate
change for the industrialized countries
and indeed the industrialized countries
they react with tremendous programs to
support their economies
uh in U.S in Europe in all
industrialized countries not with
spillions with trillions
and now the question
what is the support for
two-thirds of the world for the
developing countries these countries are
hit hardest by the pandemic the first
step there was no vaccine for for these
countries a climate change who is most
affected U.S
or Germany No Sudan the Zara region and
what is about the support for these
countries
what is about the support from the G20
and the G7 nothing nothing
they read they reduced they reduced the
budget for developing Aid the last year
that is the reaction of the
industrialized countries
concerning this triple crisis
Mr Houseman you've done a lot of uh work
with the growth Lab at Harvard and on
policy I wonder what your perspective is
well I I mean I would like to live in a
world where there was more support for
development but I typically work with
countries that have to deal with the
situations that they have and
um I would like to make some interesting
distinctions I hope they're interested
in any way on on on how they are
thinking or they should think about the
industrial policies the first one is
what we call you know we want to think
about the Intensive margin that is you
want to think about the needs of the
industries that you have or do you want
to think about the extensive margin so
you know the attracting Industries you
don't yet have so you know the
industries that you have can complain
the industries that you don't have don't
complain and don't tell you what they
need so how do you move into new areas
because development is all about you
know expanding your set of capabilities
into new things then you want to think
about
do you want broad-based subsidies like
the ones that these trillions of dollars
that have been put on the table that you
don't have as a developing country or do
you want to focus more on what you might
want to call the public goods the
relatively specific public goods whether
there is infrastructure regulation rules
like the ones that ministers was telling
us about
um the the the truck drivers in in
Britain right that in the 22 other
measures right and that means that you
need to have a government that has the
bandwidth
to focus on on the different many issues
that different many verticals are going
to face right
um
number
three industrial policies have been
discussed a lot sometimes at the
national level sometimes at the regional
level even for example in Britain or the
US yeah
and maybe at the global level but maybe
and and I think we're going to get there
when we discuss climate change but on
the on many policies are about some
laggard regions whether it's the rust
built in the U.S or the North in Britain
developing countries have the same story
that they have they might have parts of
the countries that are developing say
around Bangkok or around in you know
Monterey but other parts of the places
are left behind you want to tilt
Economic Development there how do you
achieve economies of agglomeration there
then typically these countries have a
complete divorce between their
universities and business the countries
have converged in terms of the number of
people that are going to University a
University enrollment is
in seeing Latin America's 90 plus
percent of U.S rates of enrollment and
but we are a two percent patenting rates
so
close the gap on education we're not
closing the gap on Innovation and that
has to do with
structures of University policy that are
divorced from structures of industrial
policy
um
I think training is is an area that some
countries have figured out better than
others you know people are very
impressed by Switzerland Germany but the
secret there is that you use the
companies themselves to train the
workers and you acknowledge the fact
that they're providing a public good and
by the way you treat their expenditures
on on training by the way you help them
in training and by the way certify what
they've did in their training so I think
that's a huge space and finally I would
like to mention mobility in in
developing countries a a the cost of
going to work is a much higher fraction
of income simply because you know cars
are cost more or less the same
everywhere and gasoline costs more or
less the same everywhere but salaries
are not the same everywhere they're much
lower in developing countries that makes
transportational costs much more
significant and if you have very
inefficient Urban Development where you
know densities are not there and the
terms in transportation systems are not
there
the cost of just going to work in terms
of direct cost and time and opportunity
cost Etc it makes it very inefficient
for to go to work and very hard for
firms to attract workers and make them
less competitive so these are the issues
that I think are on the table when you
think about Industrial Products Mr
Husband you mentioned Innovation and
Technology I want to bring Minister Lee
into the conversation and your role in
supporting entrepreneurs and and new
technologies have also disrupted we saw
I'm just a small example we've really
well covered in the pandemic of
mobilization of just the
vaccine manufacturing and you know new
companies getting into everything from
the development to the delivery I want
to hear the perspective from South Korea
and if our guests could please put the
headphones on for obviously thank you
um
foreign
foreign
foreign
are using Digital Data to reduce carbon
footprint thank you oh thank you thank
you for that answer and and I and I
think you bring up a good point many of
the panelists have spoken to about
climate change and that's also a driving
force Mr gervris let's go back to you
from I'd love to hear about how you're
addressing that we and and thinking
about decarbonizing
the process the manufacturing
distribution and you have many lines of
business from nutritional products to
engineering materials so I would love to
hear what changes you put in place we're
thinking about it
I think the interesting is that the
whole decarbonation the carbonization on
climate change is a joint effort because
it's such a complex problem that you
can't just have a mono-dimensional view
so that's also why I like these type of
discussion because it needs governments
and these consumers it needs the
industry to make that work so
I think first and foremost we need to
agree that we have different roles to
play so I think governments need to set
the box within we can play
and then within that box companies like
ours need to play
um certainly in a transition where we go
to more climate action where there's a
carbon price where you price waste in
the right way
I think governments have a huge role to
play because they need to set the box
right
but they should not play in that box
for instance today even today fossil
fuels are still heavily subsidized in
some other countries so you set the Box
in the transition but you also Play In
The Box by continuing giving that
subsidy so what we should not do is in
that whole transition to a more
carbon-free environment that we continue
to subsidize
non-valid business models what the
government need to do is to play the box
and say okay if you have an industry
where there are high Emissions on on co2
you pay a certain price a carbon price
I'm a strong believer in that and that
starts innovation
but in the transition it needs to help
because we need to act and we need to
work together a nice example we have a
product which is called beauvair which
you add to premix for for for for cattle
for cow and that reduces the methane
emissions so as you probably know cows
are are emitting quite some amount of
methane by the way not from the back but
from the front
um I also have to learn that and if you
add that premix enzyme it reduces with
30 to 50 percent
that's a fantastic solution to help
climate change
we went to the farmer and we said listen
you need to have this fantastic product
of ours and it reduces methane we can
show it scientifically and the farmers
say well
you offer me a product for a solution I
don't see the problem well you have a
problem because your cows are meeting me
things so yeah that's not my problem so
you should need to go to the government
so we went to the government and the
government said okay well great product
fantastic Etc but I mean you need no
need to come to us you need to go to the
farmer because is there a problem and
then we say yeah well now we got stock
we got this Brilliant Invention
and nobody sees their
there we've learned that we need to
engage with the governments to make sure
that the farmer feels it's a problem
and then we come in and not that we
subsidize the product to make a
transition so I think it needs to be
clear where we play in the box where the
governors need to set the box and on on
sustainability or climate change
we have the economic system which worked
pretty well the only failure is
that we don't price waste and
externalities in the right way so if
there is a mission on carbon if their
mission on methane you need to price
that in the cost of your product and I
think we're in that transition and I'm
hopeful but it can can go a little bit
quicker and secretary chaps any thoughts
on that and Mr Jeffries are talking
about incentives here
um and there's consumer incentives I
think many of us saw in our flights to
you know you know deep offset your your
air flight and but we're talking about
larger bigger boxes disagree yes
absolutely agree I love this example
with the methane product for for cows
and of course why would a farmer you
know the farmer doesn't have any costs
right personally to that methane uh
being uh being being put out there of
course government's got to act but
here's the thing a government doesn't
want to act on that on its own because
it will put its own farmers at a
competitive disadvantage
um so this has to be solved globally and
you mentioned Aviation is a fantastic
example and there is a global effort
that's called corsia which is a process
of
essentially costing the uh the carbon
output from Aviation and as long as you
do that on a global basis and everyone's
in the same position and the costs are
the same then you know then of course it
then becomes immediately interesting to
switch to other things such as
sustainable aviation fuel the switch to
potentially hydrogen what have you so in
government this has been a lot of what
I've been dealing with I just give you
two examples starting with Aviation we
set up something called the jet zero
Council and this brings together to to
your point the academics with the
government with the industrial sector uh
all three of them together to work on
how we get to Net Zero flight by 2050.
and we're making some significant
progress we've had the first aircraft
fly on hydrogen it was a a Rolls-Royce
EasyJet flight there's an American
company but it's impression called zero
Avia working on an engine I've gone to
see it which is going to be hydrogen
operated they're about to do their first
test in fact the owner of that zero Avia
company is here at the world economic
Forum the sustainable aviation fuel
Market is really starting to get going
and we're doing that through regulation
so the EU have said five percent of fuel
by the end of the decade will have to be
using sustainable aviation fuel which at
least doesn't put more carbon out there
the UK is going for a higher Target
we're saying 10 we like to lead on this
bluntly so we can get the factories in
the UK the US I suspect will will catch
up on on on saf uh now so you start to
get a world movement around the
regulation that's involved and then
specifically on energy production
because in the UK we closed our coal
mines actually under Thatcher
controversially at the time in the 80s
and then a bit in the 90s we ended up
decarbonizing very very quickly almost
none of our energy comes from uh coal
these days one percent Maybe
um but but we had to find an alternative
in our alternative 10 12 years ago I was
in the government back then it was under
David Cameron was to build wind farms uh
particularly offshore and I remember we
came up with this mechanism the contract
for difference where we'd guarantee the
price to the uh manufacturer to the to
the to the Constructor
um and uh I just remember being in a
cabinet meeting and Cameron saying
this is crazy this is going to cost more
than nuclear power which is
traditionally an expensive form of power
but extremely reliable this is going to
cost more well what are we doing should
we do this we we made the decision a
decade ago to go ahead with it today
in fact literally yesterday or last week
we would have been producing 50 60 70 of
all of our electricity from wind mostly
offshore wind we have the world's
largest
second largest the third largest
in the next auction for contracts for
differences I've seen the bids
the
scale and size of the turbines to
produce these the the the the
electricity are so large that the arms
of the of the turbines if you took seven
football pitches and put them together
that is the sweep of the turbine going
around and you put 300 of these enormous
turbines next to each other so that is
brilliant but the wind doesn't always
blow the sun doesn't always shine so you
know you still have to look for one of
the other Alternatives whether it's
nuclear or small modular reactors or
what have you right cost of energy is
competitive right that's yes that's the
beauty of it so you don't need to
subsidize it now I mean sorry 10 years
on from this Cameron conversation in
cabinet now it is amongst the the
cheapest strike price for Energy and we
no longer have to subsidize so so it's
been a real achievement through getting
the regulatory framework and taking a
risk it needs to be said yeah I'm taking
along the long term yeah right and and
we're talking about crisis but having to
think long term Mr Houseman Mr Mueller
what other long-term thinking needs to
happen here are policies I I think the
world has benefited a lot from this
focus of saying you know the world needs
to lower its emissions every country
needs to lower its emissions every city
needs to lower its emissions every value
chain needs to lower its emissions and
and that's sort of like a very it's been
a useful way of understanding what needs
to happen in order for the world to
lower its missions but I think it leads
a very very huge chapter and even maybe
even bigger chapter out of out of focus
you can ask Bolivia to say you should
lower your emissions
but honestly if they lowered their
emissions to zero no one will notice
right
they happen to be sitting on the largest
lithium reserves in the world
they could do things that help the world
lower its emissions
and this so it's not just about what are
you going to do to lower your emissions
what are you going to do to enable the
rest of the world to lower its emissions
and that implies for example we will
need wind farms or are they going to be
produced we need solar panels we're
electrolyzer we need lithium we need
liquor we'll need Cobalt we'll need Etc
there's a lot that needs to be produced
to help the world decarbonize so I think
it's important to take the picture how
it is that this developing World which
is supposed to buy all these equipments
to have green energy what how it is that
they're going to have the world or
provide things to the world so that they
have the experts with which to import
stuff they have a role to play and here
there's an important issue
about about a renewable energy renewable
energy is different from oil in the fact
that oil was incredibly cheap to
transport and because it was incredibly
cheap to transport the price of oil was
essentially equal everywhere and that
meant that energy poor countries could
specialize in energy intensive products
so for example Japan Korea Belgium and
Germany could export Steel
they don't have much energy no problem
they bring it in well bringing in green
energy is much much more expensive we
don't have the Technologies to move it
around so I think what's going to happen
is that the world will want to locate
energy intensive activities near Green
sources of energy green sources of
Cheaper cheap green sources of energy
and I think that would lead to a
re-accommodation of where the world
produces things and it should start
producing more things close to where a
green energy is unfortunately there's a
lot of sun in the tropics
and now we are at the pond it's very
important that this great what happens
in the UK in Europe in g20s
but net zeroed when the 50s only
possible
this a green deal with Investments with
new technologies in the in the in the
developing countries to that of people
are living there yeah and
energy is the basic for every
development especially industrialization
and look to Africa the African continent
600 people do not have access to
electricity
energy electricity that's the first step
for industrialization and of course the
G20 are responsible for 80 percent of
the emissions
and therefore that is very important to
go ahead with technology and with all
these messages
but the developing countries pays a
price for the consequences of climate
change again they pay the price and they
need more solidarity look about this
promise of 100 billion uh the G20
offered 100
billion five years ago oh and what is
the reality they paid a 30 billion loans
loans so look at chamel Sheikh the
results there was no decision about the
loss and damage and that is of this
situation the developing countries need
and you need is the platform for
technology transfer especially in this
field of energy of course they need
tremendous investments in renewable
energies in hydrogen but even
in carbon capture
because the reality is 80 percent of
world energy today is based on fossil
fuel and it will be based the next 10 or
20 years and there is because of
population growth the next 20 years the
next 30 Years
Africa will double they need energy they
need chops hundreds of millions of chops
and the basic is energy and still today
in African countries they blend Coal
Power stations 300 cold power stations
still today are planned by big companies
and so that is the reality the demand
for energy the next 30 years built by it
will about 70 percent
and mainly based on the fossil fuel in
Nigeria talk about this the Nigerian
government or Mozambique uh that is
based energies based on cold air and
what do they need they need new
technologies progressed by Innovation
carbon capture carbon storage carbon
usage
that we have to bring forwards and um we
have we must come to a closer
cooperation partnership between
industrialized countries emerging and
developing countries in technology
partnership in sharing our knowledge and
I like and I know and the UK is doing a
lot in this field but not so much from
U.S there's nearly nothing they cut the
development Aid and that is the reality
too we are here in the walls uh that
should be not only a discussion about
what happens within the G20
um there's a commitment from the
industrialized countries to support the
developing countries and two-thirds of
the world in the future in the future in
the near future in 20 or 30 years
85 of people in the world live in
developing countries Africa will double
within the next 20 years we need answers
to these questions really important
point I want to make sure we're running
a little bit of a shorter in time yes
foreign foreign
so I think we need to really have a new
approach to decarbonization yeah thank
you Minister Lee for that perspective as
well we've had such a great conversation
here I think we've run out of time we
won't have time for Q a but I just want
to thank my distinguished panelists here
for we had a wide-ranging conversation
covered a lot of ground thank you so
much for the conversation conversation
thank you for joining us online that
concludes the session on the future of
industrial policies thank you very much
thank you